hi everyone my name is olson lee and i'm
a senior product manager for the google
cloud
working on key management and obviously
cloudhsn
and with me i have audit singha who's
one of our tech leads for cloud hsm to
talk about
cloud h7 and give you a deep dive and
best practices around the service itself
now in this session we'll talk first
about the hsm overview
and give you an idea of what cloud hsm
is and what it can do for you and then
highlight some of the key features for
cloud hsm
and then i'll turn over to audit who
allows you to talk more about the
overall architecture
and talk about you know some of the key
aspects of the architecture such as the
tent separation and the google access
administrative access so start off with
let's
go and talk a little bit about the
overview of cloud hsm
so that picture there is actually a real
picture of one of the cards that we have
inside our data centers and this is a
cavem
liquid security hsm that black stuff you
see all around it
is actually epoxy that's used to provide
the tamper evidence and tamper
resistance
for the cloud for the card itself and
it's one of the requirements for the
card to be one
a fips 140-2 card and i'll explain a
little bit more about that in a bit
but the cloud hsm service is basically
hsn as a managed service and so if
you're not familiar with hsms
they're hardware security modules
they're basically industry
devices that are used hardware devices
are used to actually protect
generate key material and also perform
crypto operations
now the cloudhsn that we provide
is actually a fully managed service that
google provides as you can see in the
diagram there
a request comes in it goes through the
key management service front end
and then based upon the type of key you
created it either goes to the software
path or the hardware path and if it's in
the hardware path
our cloud hsn service will orchestrate
the operations to occur within one of
the actual fiscal hsms
so the the architecture actually lends
itself to being a full cloud service and
i won't talk too much about this because
in a few
few slides i will talk more about this
but what i mean is that we'll take care
of all the patching for you
so you don't have to worry about any of
the physical maintenance from our
upgrades or anything else like that
it's all done without any downtime so it
doesn't really make a difference
it doesn't really impact you from
availability perspective
we also auto scale this in terms of
requests as well so if you have a lot of
requests
then our service will just be able to to
to fulfill all those requests as well uh
within the limits of your quota
and the other thing is that you don't
have to worry about backups and
having any kind of business continuity
strategy because we'll take care of that
for you as well
so you know we'll take care of the
backups we have a very very highly
redundant system
that'll make sure that your key material
is very secure
and that the chances of losing your keys
are actually extremely small to
almost completely you know completely
unlikely
and the other thing about the hsn's as
well is that they're all
with contained within our very secure
facilities
so you know they're they're basically
inherit all the physical securities that
all our our
servers and all the other devices have
within our our
data centers and they basically uh
you know provides provides a level of
security that will be pretty hard to
impersonate
outside of a cloud provider
now why would you use cloud hsm there's
a number of reasons so number one
it's typically compliance so a lot of
people
use cloud hsm or hsms in general because
they're looking for a certification from
nist
and it's essentially fips 140-2 level 3
that our hsms are currently running in
now what that means is that
the fips 140-2 is a crypto standard
devised by nist again
and it defines things like you know what
your render number generations
the type of algorithms you know key
types
things like that the level three
is basically only attainable through
hardware devices and it dictates things
like
you know like the physical tamper
temporary evidence and tamper-proofness
of the of the device itself
so that you can't get in there and
physically you know like try to extract
the keys
or it's very difficult to do so
visualization is also another key aspect
of the service
where when you actually create a key
within a specific region
let's say that it's us central one then
that key only exists within us central
one
and not only the key but also the the
metadata
all the backups everything else
associated with that so wherever you
create the key that's where it'll be
now cloud hsm also provides an
additional level of
regional affinity based on the fact that
when you create the keys it's associated
with a set of hsms
that are physically within that region
if that key was ever
you know if you ever try to actually
decrypt that key in a different region
it's not possible
and you'll understand what i'm talking
about a little bit more when ada talks
about the architecture but
essentially that key can only ever be
used by those devices within that region
and then finally the last thing and i'll
just reiterate is that
it leverages the exact same apis as
cloud kms
and what that really means is that if
you already know how to use cloud kms
then you know how to use cloud hsn in
any application that uses cloud kms can
use cloud hsm including
uh all the internal integrations that we
have as well so
all the services are integrated with our
cloud kms we'll be able to use
hsms without any kind of changes it's
only when you create the key you specify
protection level and that's it
now talking in terms of key features
there are
three that i'd like to actually kind of
cover in a little more detail
and those are the global multi-regional
support the agitation statements
and the cmec integration and cmx stands
for customer management encryption keys
now in terms of the global
multi-regional support
um first of all we we have cloud hsn
available
in all our cloud regions so any region
that you choose today
should have cloud hsn available with it
as well and so
you know it has a large footprint and
it's probably one of the largest
um you know footprints for for hsn
service that you'll find anywhere to be
quite honest
um the other thing is that it will be
you you have the capability of actually
creating a multi-region with their cloud
hsn keys
and what that means is that when you
create a key in a multi-region
it's available across that geography
so for example if you create a key
within the us region
then that key is accessible through
through different areas within the
united states it's available across the
across the country so that if uh for for
whatever reason
your particular region goes dark which
hopefully never happens
then that key exists in other areas and
other
regions or not other other parts of the
country so that your application can
migrate over to a different
different part of the country and the
key will just be there it will be
completely available
and when you make changes to a key in a
multi-region the key
the changes are reflected everywhere so
it it happens in
almost instantaneously so it's it's
truly a multi-region it's not
a backup and restore so in other
other schemes you may see systems where
you actually are basically
taking your backup and restoring and
cloning it to a different region so that
you basically kind of mimic
uh having having two regions and having
a kind of business continuity solution
ours is a little more automated than
that just to find your key to being a
multi-region and just exist there now
we recently also announced support for
global
global regional support which means that
if you create a key within the global
region
that key becomes available across around
the globe
so a key that's created for example
united states may be
also available in india or also
available across europe
if you create it as a global key and for
anyone who's actually worked
directly with hsn you know that that is
a
pretty pretty special thing to be able
to do
because creating clusters with hsms is
not that simple especially in spans
massive geographies
and because of the because of the
architecture that we chose
that audio will explain in bit you'll
see why
we can actually do things like this
which makes it truly like the cloud
service
the second thing i want to cover is is
ada station statements
what an anastasia statement is is that
it's a statement that's signed
by the hsm using a certificate by the
hsn vendor
that attests to the the key
and the properties around the keys being
inside the hsm
so if you create a key uh with using our
apis
then you can download the attestation
statement verify the signature and know
that that key
is definitely inside or created by one
of our hsms
and when you perform encrypt operation
it will happen within the hsm itself
now the other things you can do with
that attestation statement is
that you can look at the various
properties of the keys including things
like
whether the key is extractable or not so
you can actually get
verifiable proof that that key material
cannot be taken out of hsm in plain text
and that google can't do this either and
so this is something that will probably
make your auditors very happy
um other things that you can do are you
know look at the different properties
one of the more interesting ones is that
if you actually are using a
asymmetric key you can actually download
the sha-256 hash of the public key
itself
so when you download the public key from
cloud hsm
you can take the sha-256 hash compared
to the one that's in the average station
statement
if they match then you know that the
you're talking to the right key
and that you know you're you have
cryptographic proof that you're talking
to a key within the hsm
the final thing i'll talk about is uh
customer managed encryption keys
support services so all the services
that you see here are
already integrated with our cloud kms so
there's nine of them listed in the
integrated services um and on the verge
of the fact that we've designed cloud
hsm to
leverage the exact same api it means
that anywhere where
cloud kms can be used you can actually
leverage cloud hsn as well
the only difference is again is that
when you create the key there's a
different flag that you set
and so it's probably one of the fastest
experiences you'll ever have in creating
a key in hsn
and then with that key you can actually
use it to protect your data in for
example
cloud sql or gcs or bigquery or any of
the services listed there
the cma compliant services are services
that don't persist
data in any link any significant length
of time
which is why they're cmec compliant and
if you look at the url that i have the
bottom
slide this page will be constantly
updated with new services that we add
because
we're we're constantly trying to add
more services uh to the supported list
for cloud kms and cloud hsn
and with that i'm going to add
three more things i want to actually
talk about
so first customers um
pay for key operations not capacity so
what we're saying here is that you know
cloud hsn is actually a consumption
based model
you don't have to basically purchase an
entire partition
or partitions or clusters of partitions
you basically pay for
every crypt operation every key that you
create so
it's i believe right now it's three
cents for 10 000 operations for most
type of operations
and it's about a dollar a month per key
so you know
you can use as much as you want you can
use as little as you like uh
it's basically there's no kind of
upfront cost to this and there's no
commitment
there's no additional cost for
multi-regional operations so
despite the fact that this key can span
multiple
multiple um or like a vast geography we
don't charge you any extra for that it's
basically the same cost i just quoted
above
and then finally the high availability
is inherent
as a property of the service itself so
there's
no requirement for you to actually you
know take backups store the backups
or do anything else like that we have a
very very robust system that takes very
very frequent backups
and actually takes the the key material
and actually backs them up into the
disparate system as well so that we
were resilient against failures of you
know
any particular any particular data store
so with that now i'm going to turn over
to audit who's going to talk a little
bit more about the
architectural overview
thanks ilsum well i feel some saddle go
into more details
about how the architecture works and
i'll hopefully make it clear
how all the features that nilssang
talked about fall out of our design
i'll go more into detail about a lot of
different aspects but to start with i
want to talk about
some of the design principles that we
have behind our system
first we want to reduce user api access
hsms are inherently complex devices
and are somewhat of black boxes in order
to
try to prevent customers from launching
attacks against the hsms
and the service we want to restrict the
types of operations they're allowed to
do
second one of the major reasons to move
to the cloud
is to no longer need to manage your own
devices
we want cloudhsn to fit in that same
cluster
experience as wilson said we want
customers to pay for a consumption model
not for having to provision
their resources beforehand and third
a lot of customers have compliance
requirements around where their keys are
geographically located
we want strong cryptographic and
administrative controls
to make sure that we can maintain these
requirements
the system that we've designed for these
principles
looks slightly different than a normal
hsm in the cloud model
in the traditional model you would have
crypto op access represented by the blue
arrows
and admin access represented by the red
arrows
to your own partition on the hsm the
cloud provider would have admin access
to the device as a whole
which they would use for operations like
setting the hsm up initially for you
in contrast in cloud hsm you only get
crypto op
access that access is to
shared partitions on the hsm and it's
mediated by the cloud hsm service
google retains admin access to both the
partitions
and the hsm device the cloud hsm service
is responsible for load balancing and
controlling
access to the hsm it can see plain texts
but can't see key material since these
are fips devices
raw key material must remain on the hsm
instead the service can see wrapped key
material
which it uses extensively in
the system to make it scalable and
highly available
each region has a wrapping key that's
replicated to a partition
on all of the hsms in the region when
you create a key
the service wraps your key with the
region's wrapping key
and collects the attestation it puts the
wrapped key
in an external database when you want to
do a crypto operation
the service will retrieve the wrap key
from the database
and send it to an hsm along with the
inputs to the crypto operation
for example with the plain text in an
encryption
the hsm will unwrap the key and do the
operation
this scheme has a few benefits first
as soon as your key is created any hsm
in the region can use it immediately
there's no synchronization mechanism
that needs to happen
online second
the durability of your keys isn't tied
to
the hsms your keys are all backed up in
an external database
and third regardless of the number of
operations that you have or the number
of keys that you have
all customers experience the
availability of being backed
by a full region's worth of hsms in
order to scale up in this model
we'll install a new hsm in the data
center
for the region and clone the region's
wrapping key to that new hsm
additionally if the region is supposed
to support a multi-region
we'll clone the multi-region wrapping
key to a separate partition
for example here we have three cloud
regions
the first two of which also support the
same multi-region
the hsms in the first two cloud regions
have
a second partition that is cloned with
the same multi-regional wrapping key
the hsms and cloud region 3 don't have
the second partition
because the region doesn't support the
multi-region
when you create a key in a multi-region
the process looks very similar to that
as a region cloud
the cloud sim service creates the key in
the partition and wraps it
this means that as soon as you create a
key in a multi-region
it can be used immediately anywhere in
that multi-region
we bootstrap off the rest of google's
synchronized databases
also by using separate wrapping keys
for different regions and different
multi-regions
the service ensures that keys can't be
used
outside their intended region for
example
a key wrapped with the region 1 wrapping
key
can't be used in cloud region 2 because
none of the hsms in region 2 can load
that key
likewise a key wrapped with the
multi-regional wrapping key
can't be used in cloud region 3 for the
same reason
this ensures that once we've set the
system up
it automatically enforces
regionalization constraints
setting the system up that is cloning
the wrapping keys across different hsms
is an administrative operation and we
have a different set of controls
to make sure that happens safely first
only a small number of googlers
have permission to perform admin
operations
the operations require mvn authorization
on the hsms so the hsms require multiple
googlers to
authorize each operation and googlers
need to provide two-factor
authentication in order to do so
all the operations happen in a secure
and highly restricted access
facility we have extensive audit logs
both for access to the facility and
all the operations that happen inside
additionally as also mentioned that
these are fips devices
they don't allow specific operations
regardless of who is doing them even hsm
administrator
for example you can't export plain text
key material
of either customer keys or wrapping keys
and finally many of our systems are
built in such a way to
not allow hsm administrators to perform
crypto operations
even with administrator credentials we
have all these mechanisms in place
to keep you safe from googlers other
customers
on the other hand only have crypto
operation access
so to keep you safe from them we have a
different set of mechanisms
first when a customer does an operation
we check whether they have permission to
do the operation
in cloud iam by using cloud iam
you can use the same set of permissions
and policies that you use to manage the
rest of your cloud resources
to also manage your hsm keys second
we check that the customer has
sufficient quota to do the operation
in order to make sure that we have
enough resources
to serve requests for your workloads
when you need them
we need to make sure that other
customers aren't unexpectedly
overloading the service
and third we have basic request
validation before the request reaches
the hsm
for example we check that different
arguments are within their expected
range in size and also the key types are
correct
this coupled with the fact that there is
no customer admin access
significantly reduces the attack surface
available
creating a safer product in summary
we've covered
quite a few details about about how the
cloud hsm
service works we've seen how we use
key wrapping and partitions to make a
highly available
and scalable service that takes away the
need
for you to manage your own hsm devices
we've seen how this system keeps you
safe
from both googlers and from other
customers through our administrative
controls
and tenant isolation we've seen how
you can easily create keys in regions
and multi-regions and the consequence of
all these design decisions
is that it is as easy to protect your
data both
in google services and directly
as it is with a software key we'll have
all of these details
and more in an upcoming cloudhsn white
paper
so please keep your eye out for that
thank you